[Applause]  now it's Russell driving on Colin stops  oh the window  as Conley touches Earth ice in his veins  D'Angelo Russell ties it up 4.4 to go  [Applause]  beautifully done although I I don't know  there was a little confusion as to when  they were going to go with 20 seconds  and no timeouts down by two if you'd  like to give yourself a chance you don't  want to run the clock down towns was  calling for govir to come out and set  the screen Rudy said wait wait wait but  then challenge pisen Urban Dilo who  takes Mike Connolly on beautiful stop in  power right there off the glass it's  right in that's right in dilo's  wheelhouse too right so  Minnesota ties the game it looked it  looked like all was lost right and  here's the other thing too here what in  this situation is that Minnesota does  have a foul to give so  you've done a great job here of  Defending without